Sure. I'll give you a short answer.
We're talking about daniel chapter 12.
If you understand Daniel chapter 12, you
cannot take Daniel chap chapter 12 out
of context. Daniel chapter 2, we look at
Babylon, meet Persia, Greece, Rome, the
break up of the Roman Empire, the um the
coming of Christ. Daniel chapter 7,
Babylon, Meet Persia, Greece, Rome, the
break up of the Roman Empire, the rise
of the little horn, the papacy, and then
um the coming of Christ or the judgment
and the coming of Christ. That's Daniel
7:8-9. Now, what many people want to do
is they want to reinterpret the 1290
days and the 1335 and put it down at the
time of the end. But there's no
justification for that in Bible
prophecy. Now, when you look at Daniel
chapter 12, it says this in Daniel 12.
We'll start there with verse 9
through13.
I've just written a new book on Daniel
and Revelation. It'll be published
shortly. So, I can't take a half an
hour, an hour to give you a full answer,
but I will give you enough. Daniel 12 is
the climax of the book. You wouldn't
expect the climax to be different than
the rest of the book. So the 1260 days,
the three and a half times 538 to 1798
have been mentioned earlier in the book.
You you would expect the 1290 and the
1335 to be tied into what we've studied
already, not to just be pulled out of
context, put at the time of the end. So
the Bible says here Daniel 12 starting
with verse 9 and he said go your way
Daniel for the words are closed up and
sealed till the time of the end. Now
when did the time of the end begin?
According to the book of Daniel it began
sometime after 1798. Many shall be
purified made white and refined but the
wicked shall do wickedly. None of the
wicked shall understand but the wise
shall understand. What's this idea that
the uh wise are going to understand?
What are they going to understand?
Daniel's prophecies. At the end of the
2,300 days, the judgment began. It was
the antityypical day of atonement. God
was calling all men and women to repent,
to open their hearts, to be purified by
God's grace and charmed by his love and
changed by his power. That's verse 10.
Verse 11. From the time the daily
sacrifice was taken away. So when was
that taken away? And the abomination of
desolation set up there shall be uh
1,290
days. What's that's talking about when
this abomination of desolation is set up
in 538
AD
the Justinian the pagan Roman emperor
gave to the pope of Rome vigilous 2
civil and religious authority
but in 508
that process began historically as the
papacy gained its power and finally
drove the Ostrogos out of Rome by 538.
But in actual fact in 508 that began
that whole process began. So here the
prophecy takes us back to 508 when the
process begins. If you add 1290 that'll
take you to 1798. So there's a process.
The 1260 years begin when the process
ends in 538 takes you down to 1798. The
1290 begins in the process begins in 508
to give the papacy uh supremacy its
authority and it takes you down to 1798.
The time of the end begins. What about
this 1335? If you begin at 508, it'll
take you down to 1843 and on to 1844,
the advent movement where God's would
point his people from the earthly
sanctuary to the heavenly sanctuary to
complete his work on earth. So it says
here, "Blessed is he who awaits and
comes to the 1,335 days." What's that?
That is to say that blessed is the man
who lives in the judgment hour after
1844, that understands the truths of the
sanctuary, that opens his heart to
receive the grace and power of God in
the judgment for the finishing of God's
work.